it's it's hard to speak uh but uh
80 years ago
uh
representatives of nine countries met
nine nations met in london
to
set up a legal framework
for persecution of for prosecution
of war criminals
during the second world war
and we all know that led to the
establishment of a president in
international law that
basically
defined the future development of uh
international criminal law
now eight years ago eight years ago
russia launched an aggression against
ukraine
occupying crimea
uh some parts of our territory in
eastern ukraine
and eight days ago
eight full days ago
russia
in a barbar in a rather barbarian way
launched another wave of aggression
against ukraine it's a full-fledged
aggression masks off
uh and uh the question is now how the
international community will handle it
we welcome the
initiative of the international criminal
court to investigate
um
crimes which fall in its your
jurisdiction namely war crimes and
crimes against humanity
the prosecutor of international criminal
court
has also demonstrated leadership in this
in this effort
and ukraine will cooperate
fully with icc while not being a full
full uh party to to the conflict to to
the rome statute but we recognize
jurisdiction
uh on crimes on war crimes and crimes
against humanity since 2014
and so the moment i learned about the
initiative to set up
a tribunal a multinational tribunal
to
investigate the crime of aggression
against ukraine
i immediately said yes
and this yes comes from me not only as a
person but also
as a representative of the government of
ukraine
we appreciate the initiative we are
looking we are looking forward to
working actively on it
and also to engage with those countries
who are willing to uh
to
take part in this in this important
undertaking
the
this in the aim of this initiative is
not to replace uh international criminal
court or any other
uh jurisdictional bodies
but to fill the gap that exists in
international law
and to use to experience
of international community and
international law
for the benefit of the people and of the
world order based on international law
when bombs fall on your cities when
soldiers rape
women in the occupied cities and we have
numerous cases unfortunately when
russian soldiers rape
women in in the ukrainian cities
it's difficult of course to speak about
the efficiency of the international law
but
this is the only tool of civilization of
civilization that is available to us
to make sure
that
in the end eventually
all those
who made this war possible
will be brought to justice and the
uh
russian federation as a country that
committed an act of aggression
will also be held accountable for its
deeds
i therefore either we we are using
all tools available including icj you
may have heard about our application
on the convention on genocide
the european court of human rights
our
application to icc and i appreciate the
referral of the case by 39 countries who
are ready to support ukraine in this
but really we need to to fill the gap
on the crime of aggression
and therefore i would like to
support
the declaration and the statement
calling for the setup of the special
tribunal
for the punishment of the crime of
aggression against ukraine
the recent u.n general assembly
resolution
named aggression against ukraine
is
was supported by 141 uh country which is
unprecedented in itself
and it gives us the political ground
to
uh to move forward with this initiative
so so on behalf of the government of
ukraine once again uh we are ready to
move on
we are ready to
uh work with anyone
who is willing
to bring russia into an account and i
call on all of you who participate in
this me in this meeting to contribute to
the establishment of this tribunal and i
also call on all media who follow this
uh who follow this online meeting
to spread the truth about russia's
crimes against ukraine
and to advocate the establishment of
this of such a tribunal
thank you very much i will have to
switch off and continue my my travel
but i appreciate that all of you stand
by ukraine we are fighting
against the enemy who is much stronger
than us but the international law is on
our side and hopefully it will help us
it will make its own contribution to
help us prevail thank you